the bio psych project is combining
genome sequence information for
thousands of organisms with inferred
metabolic pathways for those organisms
and with published information from
biomedical literature their aim is to
create a modern computable fabric for
biological knowledge in which
information is integrated for a range of
use cases you're sure to speak more
about that today thank you Peter thanks
for inviting me to speak well this
diagram is your tax dollars at work in
in multiple ways this is the biochemical
network of E coli that workhorse
laboratory microbe and you know hundreds
of scientists have spent decades piecing
together this collection of biochemical
reactions that E coli uses to convert
chemicals in its environment to more of
itself you know e.coli is this amazing
machine that can basically replicate
itself Silicon Valley has created all
sorts of amazing little wondrous
machines but I'm not aware of a
self-replicating machine that's come out
of Silicon Valley yet in the course of
figuring out this network of roughly a
thousand different biochemical reactions
each one catalyzed by a protein machine
encoded by equalised genome biologists
have published little bits and pieces of
this information across thousands of
different publications and for me what
was exciting about science as a kid was
putting all this information to figure
out how the actions of all those little
parts of this complex machine
contributed to the overall function of
the machine but how do you do that if
that information is spread across
thousands and thousands of publications
so about 20 years ago we started a
project to try to piece together all
that information to bring it under one
digital hood where we could both make an
encyclopedia that was accessible to
thousands of scientists online kind of
analogous to Wikipedia as well as create
a computable model of e.coli well we've
now done that for e.coli and we're
beginning to do it for thousands of
other
bacteria that have had their genome
sequenced and an overview view of my
talk is I want to try to pull out a few
kind of global themes of our work that
you may find of interest just as an
Anthony's talk on like how we tried to
extract lots of lessons for us from from
his work one one aspect of our work is
that our bio psych so eco psych is a an
e.coli database bio psych is a
collection of now seven thousand
different databases and 11 theme of bio
psych is to integrate diverse data and
knowledge for these thousands of genomes
in particular we're integrating both
highly curated high quality information
that people are extracting from the
scientific literature with
computationally generated inferences
because as we know it's it's very slow
and expensive to curate information so
where we can't curate it we have a
number of predictive algorithms that
predict the information another theme is
serving a diverse set of use cases that
I'll outline shortly from the
encyclopedic use case to creating an
executable model of the e.coli
biochemical network another theme has
been creating extensive domain-specific
visualization tools some of which are
based on visualizations that biologists
have developed over many decades others
of which we've developed new
visualizations but I guess 11 theme I'll
argue here is that the the computer
science graph hairballs seem kind of
ubiquitous across many domains but in my
opinion are only marginally useful you
know how useful it really is it to look
at a hairball diagram so we've we've
tried to come up with graph
visualizations that are both
domain-specific and maybe optimized for
certain properties of biological graphs
but also that don't show the entire
graph because it's kind of useless to
look at the entire graph I'll also talk
about sustainability our work has been
funded by the the gut
by the NIH for many years but the
government is showing signs of not
wanting to fund database scientific
databases even though I in my opinion
maintenance of the knowledge they create
should be part of their mission but so
we are begin we and others are beginning
to look at new financial models for
sustaining scientific databases and the
one we're looking at and we've just
begun to move to is a subscription-based
model so again I'll use our ecoli
database as as a model for what we've
done for other or other organisms as
well what we want to do for other
organisms so we've created this eco
psyche ecoli encyclopedia database it's
an organism specific database for the
best studied organism on earth which is
e coli which was first isolated back in
eighteen eighty five and our model has
been to have PhD biologists read
scientific papers enter their contents
into our database and so far the
information in eco psyche has been
derived from thirty one thirty one
thousand publications one of the things
that the curators do is to write little
summaries or what we call many reviews
of the functions of different ecoli
genes and metabolic pathways and to date
those those summaries if you add them
all up add up to about twenty three
hundred pages of information as well as
literature citations and we've had a
team of programmers over the years who
have been authoring web-based query and
visualization tools for our website and
we've also been able to derive a
quantitative metabolic model for e.coli
for that biochemical machinery that
that's really quite accurate and one
measure if its accuracy is if you remove
a gene from e-coli you can ask will the
e.coli live or not because some of the
genes have backup systems and others
don't and the model can predict whether
the bacterium can live or die with
ninety-five percent accuracy now in
general
this notion of an organism specific
database also called a model organism
database and bioinformatics these
databases are needed for a number of
reasons you probably hear a lot about a
lot of headlines about oh we've obtained
the complete genome for organism X but
actually these complete genomes are
really incomplete in a number of
respects many of the genes have no
assigned functions because the computer
programs we use to predict gene
functions are not very good still and
some of the functions that are predicted
are incorrect so over time we need to
flesh out that information and correct
the incorrect information we also need
continuous updating in these databases
to incorporate new experimental findings
on the organisms and one use of these
databases is that they become platforms
for global analyses of an organism such
as interpreting large-scale data sets
like gene expression data sets for
predicting essential genes as I just
mentioned one reason you'd like to know
which genes if if removed from an
organism will kill the organism is
that's that's how antimicrobial drugs
work is they'll basically knock out a
given gene and kill the organism so when
you're designing new drugs you'd like to
know which genes are essential to the
organism and another type of global
analysis you can do is to characterize
systems properties of the metabolic
network and the genetic network of the
organism for example from a graph
theoretic point of view what is the
connectivity profile of the e.coli
metabolic network well our bio site
collection of databases contain 7600
databases and each of these pathway
genome databases contains information
about a range of different data types
from metabolic pathways that is the
sequence of biochemical reactions that
carries out some small discrete function
in the cell the databases describe
individual reactions and their chemical
substrates databases describe the the
proteins that catalyze these reactions
the genes that code for the
proteins and a lot of the regulatory
interactions that turn these genes on
and off and part of what we've done to
try to characterize the quality levels
of these different databases are to
divide them into three different tiers
where the tier 1 databases are the very
highly curated databases some of these
that databases have received person
decade's worth of curation others just a
few months depending on the amount of
funding that we've had to update the
databases so the tier two databases have
been only moderately curated and the
tier three databases have received no
curation at all and that's the largest
quantities surprise surprise these have
been purely computationally generated
from the genome sequence and it overall
if you sum up the number of literature
references in all our databases we find
that the curated information has been
extracted from 66,000 publications
across this set of databases with e.coli
being the highest by far and so I
mentioned how we combine the curated
information with computational
inferences we also combine the
computational inferences with imported
data that we import from other
bioinformatics databases for each
organism and so the overall flow of for
generating a new biopsych database is
that we obtain the genome sequence from
an NIH database called refseq we
generate a new pathway genome database
then we provide this we undertake this
whole set of computational inference
procedures where we predict the
metabolic reactions that the genome is
coding for we predict transport
reactions that bring chemicals into the
cell we predict what metabolic pathways
are present we predict which genes code
for missing steps in those metabolic
pathways we predict organization of
genes into regulatory units called
operands we predict also orthologs and p
fam domains and then we import a variety
of data from a number of other different
databases from regulatory information
to the cellular locations of different
proteins and then that's after we've
done all this automatic stuff that's
where the curation process begins if we
have enough funds to do that curation so
what is curation well in general its
ongoing manual updating and refinement
of one of these databases where we
incorporate information from the
experimental literature into the
database to try to obtain as accurate a
picture as we can about the organism it
means authoring these many reviews about
different genes and pathways and citing
our sources for all this information
filling out evidence codes that tell us
this gene function was determined by
experiment it wasn't predicted
computationally and the curators update
many different database fields to store
this information so what are some of the
uses that our users put biopsych to well
experimental biologists use it as an
encyclopedia to find out what is this
gene do in the cell what is this pathway
do in the cell computational biologists
use it to computationally study
properties of the e coli metabolic
network and regulatory Network then
bioinformatics asst who develop new
predictive algorithms use our database
as a training set for develop developing
machine learning based algorithms that
predict new aspects of cell biology from
predicting operons or promoters etc
metabolic engineers use the database as
a reference source to design new
variants of e.coli that might make
biofuels or make new drugs and educators
use it uh in their classes where they
teach microbiology
so I mentioned the different multiple
use cases that the bio psych databases
serve and let me just go through those
now one is that we have a web-based
interface where users can query genes or
pathway information about different
organisms so it's essentially using the
database as an encyclopedia we also have
a zoomable metabolic map diagram that's
generated directly from the database so
for each organism we can generate an
image of its biochemical machinery
that's somewhat like a Google map and we
can overlay that map with various types
of high-throughput data that biologists
are now generating like gene expression
data proteomics data and metabolite data
so that they can essentially see that
data in a biological context to see
which pathways are turning on and off
under a given experimental measurement
of course we also provide various query
api's that allow users to compute
against the data and we've also now
developed the ability to derive a
quantitative metabolic model from the
database so essentially the database is
now a storage platform for an executable
metabolic model that can make
predictions about the cell I'll give you
more detail on that shortly so let's
look at those perspectives in a bit more
detail so there's the online
encyclopedia article I mentioned these
mini review summaries that cover many
aspects of gene function and overall we
have about 23 hundred of these textbook
equivalent pages of these summaries so
that that's one perspective perspective
too is to view these databases queryable
databases we have about 350 different
database fields that capture different
object properties and relationships so
for example every different molecular
species is a different object in our
database and every molecular interaction
where two small molecules react to
produce another molecule or one small
molecule turns a given gene on or off
those are all represented as distinct
database objects we have a large number
of different
search tools and different AP is that
can be used to compute across the data
so i mentioned visualizations we've
developed a number of different kind of
genome scale or cellular level
visualization of cellular networks all
these visualizations are generated
automatically from the database they all
have zoom and query capabilities and
they can all be painted with
high-throughput data to visualize that
data in a biological context so the
simplest one of these diagrams is a
pathway diagram so again a pathway is
simply a set of linked biochemical
reactions that start with one input
chemical and react it according to a
number of different steps and produce
some output chemical and what we're
showing here is gene expression levels
for this pathway across a time course of
measurements that a biologist did so
that we can now see which steps of the
pathway are going up or down during this
time course where the cell was exposed
to certain different varying conditions
so we can take that up a level by now
looking at multiple pathways together so
here we're looking at more of a bird's
eye view where we're looking not just at
that one pathway but at four or five
connecting pathways that form a larger
segment of the cells overall biochemical
machinery and that if we want to see the
entire biochemical machinery we use this
version of the diagram which we can then
zoom in on we have a semantic zooming
capability where more and more details
displayed as we zoom into different
regions we can create actually a wall
chart of the biochemical machinery of
the organism that's printable and then
this is where we depict high-throughput
data against this diagram where we can
color the different reaction steps to
show how strongly those genes are being
expressed by the cell and then drill
down to see detailed expression values
for different genes within the pathway
another diagram we've developed depicts
the entire genome of the organism in one
screen so
we're looking at the complete ecoli
chromosome which although it's normally
circular here we've laid it out in a
linear fashion actually displayed as
you'd read a book so this is actually a
linear one long strand of DNA where each
little triangle here is one gene so
they're about 4,600 genes in e.coli and
they're colored according to this operon
or regulatory organization within the
cell but we can also color them
according to that same high-throughput
data set that I showed you before so
here we're looking at the expression
levels of the of these genes organized
by other their position along the genome
another diagram we've developed shows
the regulatory network of the cell we're
here we're showing all the e.coli genes
with master regulators in the middle and
unregulated genes along the outer ring
with various regulatory relationships
shown in red this is an example of
trying to go beyond the hairball where
there are many many many regulatory
interactions known here that if we
showed them all the diagram would be
completely incomprehensible so we let
the user incrementally explore which
relationships they want to see they can
start with a given gene and say show me
everything it regulates show me
everything that those genes regulate etc
ok let me now talk about this metabolic
modeling use case what metabolic
modeling lets us do is to predict what
are called the steady state reaction
fluxes for the metabolic network so
essentially that means for that big
biochemical machinery graph that I
showed you before the idea is for each
reaction we'd like to know when the cell
is growing in a given condition how much
flux or how quickly is that reaction
operating within the cell and there have
been some new modeling techniques
developed in the past ten years or so
that very nicely let us make those kinds
of predictions given very very few input
parameters about the cell and these
models led us and that was kind of an
pediment to earlier types of modeling
where you'd need thousands of parameters
none of which we could ever measure to
do other types of implement other
modeling approaches and although these
new modeling techniques have their their
limitations they do let us predict what
that set of reaction fluxes is so we can
see what's what's active to what degree
under different conditions we can
predict the growth rate of the cell
under different conditions we can
predict how fast different nutrients
will be in taken up by the cell and
again we can do this gene knockout
prediction we can computationally remove
genes and reactions from the model to
simulate knocking them out and predict
whether the cell lives or dies now one
side benefit of having these models is
that they serve in as important quality
check on the data in our database so we
essentially run these models on each new
release of the database to check whether
they still give the same results because
sometimes in the course of updating the
database we unintentionally introduce
problems that make the models not work
as well this is this is kind of a
schematic view of what these models look
like the models have four main
components the models consist of the
list of reactions that I showed you
earlier which are taken directly from
the database there's a list of the input
nutrients to the cell a list of the
waste products the cell puts out and
then a list of the biomass metabolites
or a list of all the chemicals that the
cell is making from these nutrients that
essentially form the building blocks of
the cell itself and for e.coli
interestingly you give ecoli the right
16 chemicals and it will live by taking
those chemicals in and turning them into
a hundred eight different building
blocks of itself using 2200 different
reactions and we can display the overall
flux distribution for the cell growing
under a different given condition on our
metabolic map diagram and then we can
use this that model to simulate the
growth of
coli under different conditions so for
example along the x-axis we have time
along the y axis we have the biomass of
e.coli the amount of e.coli present and
when ecoli is growing anaerobically
without oxygen it grows very slowly and
we can simulate the addition of oxygen
and the cell grows much faster than when
it uses up its source of glucose the
growth stops and it begins to die off
now one of the directions we're moving
with modeling next is to look at
modeling of a microbial community such
as in our gut microbiome the kinds of
questions we'd be able we'd like to be
able to address with a model of our gut
microbiome is if our microbiome enters
an unhealthy state how do we perturb it
back to a healthy state either by
changes in diet or giving the person a
probiotic or giving them an antibiotic
perhaps and so we're beginning to
experiment with building models for
multiple different bacteria hooking
those models together letting the
bacteria exchange nutrients there's
actually a whole little ecosystem
present in our guts where the the waste
products of one bacteria become food for
another bacteria and so this is one of
the things we're working on now and one
of the things we're trying to do is to
speed up the generation of these models
because really the hardest thing is in
this process is developing a new working
model for a given organism so we're
trying to develop computational tools to
help speed that model generation process
so i mentioned sustainability so are our
website and database files i have been
free for many years to everyone but
starting on july first we began a new
subscription model that was first
pioneered by another database called
terror which is a plant database plant
genome database that lost its funding
from the National Science Foundation a
couple years ago and so we're
essentially following the model that
they've pioneered where the basic idea
is to just like the New York Times gives
you a number a few are a number of free
article views per month we're going to
give people a number of free page views
per month from our site but once they
hit that limit they'll be asked to sign
up for a subscription and we'll offer
personal subscriptions but at least for
tear the majority of their subscriptions
are from institutions from from
companies and and mainly from academic
libraries so just as academic libraries
subscribe to scientific journals they'll
pay a given journal two thousand dollars
or five thousand dollars a year so that
everyone on campus can access that
journal that's a library a model that
university libraries are really familiar
with and so we're using essentially the
same model for access to our databases
that university libraries can purchase a
subscription that everyone on campus
will be able to access our site based on
that subscription and actually the price
that will be charged will be based on
their level of usage from the previous
year which we have web logs for so the
idea is basically for a given year
you're really paying for last year's
usage level and we're hoping that will
let us raise funds for curation of
additional databases that we have not
been funded through the government to
curate in the past so let me acknowledge
various co-workers at essar I and our
funding source at the NIH and happy to
take any questions you might have if
there's still time
you